Hey we are in front of a very special thing today
this is the east coast defender, defender 130 project viper
This is a very special custom truck
It's based off a 1986 Landrover Defender
costs about two hundred and eighty six thousand dollars
and it's meant to be able to scale a mountain
and look good going to dinner
so let's take a look
So this is pretty jacked up, this is not a low key SUV
this is really in your face truck
you kind of feel like you're in Mad Max
very furiosa style here
When East Coast Defender starts designing this for you, they literally say
what do you want us to do
and you can tailer things back based on price or functionality
but really the whole idea is that you kind of make your fantasy truck
They're only going to make ten of these per year
so if you are interested you gotta really get of it because it takes about a year to build one
and ten per year. Do the math
There aren't many that are gonna have this
So even though this car is a Defender, it actually has a lot of american components
and everything here was assembled in the US
so it's kind of cool that it's a british car but made in america
I will say though, the horn
Very british